.
WE WILL BE THERE FOR THEM.
♪ ♪
♪
>> WELCOME TO THE SPECIAL
EDITION OF "HANNITY."
TONIGHT, STRIKING AGAIN.
A DIRE BABY FORMULA SHORTAGE, OF
COURSE, THERE IS NO MYSTERY
BEHIND THIS NEW CRISIS.
IN FEBRUARY THE OWN FDA HALTED
PRODUCTION AT ONE OF THE LARGEST
BABY FORMULA PLANTS IN THE
COUNTRY.
BUT TODAY I ARE VERY INDIGNANT
PRESIDENT DECLARED THAT THERE IS
JUST NO WAY THAT HE COULD HAVE
SEEN THIS COMING.
>> A LOT OF PARENTS ARE WATCHING
ABOUT BABY FORMULA.
>> A FEW QUESTIONS, ALL OF A
SUDDEN IT'S ON THE FRONT PAGE OF
EVERY NEWSPAPER AND THAT IS
IMPORTANT.
>> SHOULD YOU HAVE TAKEN THOSE
STEPS SOONER BEFORE THIS
HAPPENED?
>> IF WE WOULD'VE BEEN BETTER
MIND READERS, I GUESS WE COULD
HAVE, BUT WE MOVED AS QUICKLY AS
IT BECAME APPARENT TO US.
WE HAVE TO MOVE WITH CAUTION AS
WELL AS SPEED.
Tammy: IT'S ON THE COVER OF
THE NEWSPAPERS, SO HE HAS TO
DEAL WITH IT.
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THEIR
ALLIES ARE PUTTING BLAME, A
"WASHINGTON POST" FACT CHECKER
CALLED IT AN OUTRAGE.
AND YESTERDAY THE PRESS
SECRETARY SPOKE OUT AND BETTE
MIDLER SAID TRY BREAST-FEEDING,
IT'S FREE AND AVAILABLE ON
DEMAND.
MEANWHILE, ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL
PLACED BLAME ON A WOMAN WANTING
TO STARVE SMALL CHILDREN IN THE
GOVERNMENT STOCKPILING FORMULA
FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
AND ANOTHER BLAME THE UNITED
STATES FOR NOT HAVING FEDERALLY
PAID MATERNITY LEAVE.
>> I THINK THE FAULT LIES IN THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE TERRIBLE
MATERNITY LEAVE, A LOT OF WOMEN
WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO STAY
HOME AND BREAST-FEED THEIR
CHILDREN AND TAKE CARE OF THEIR
CHILDREN AND THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THAT WE CANNOT DO THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE VERY LIMITED
MATERNITY LEAVE AND WE HAVE TO
IMMEDIATELY GO BACK TO WORK TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR FAMILY, TO FEED
OUR FAMILY, AND THE GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T SUPPORT IT AND THAT.
Tammy: MY GOODNESS, IT JUST
NEVER ENDS.
THE CRISIS IS NOT GOING AWAY.
IN FACT, NO ONE SEEMS TO KNOW
WHEN THIS PROBLEM WILL BE
RESOLVED.
>> DO YOU CONSIDER THIS A
CRISIS?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT A
LABEL.
IT'S ABOUT FIGURING OUT THE
TIMELINE OF WHEN IT WILL BE
FIXED.
AND WE ARE WORKING TO DO IT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT GOING TO STAND
HERE AND TELL YOUR AUDIENCE THAT
I CAN GIVE YOU A HARD TIME LIME
BUT I CAN